so I'm making guys how you doing we have
some guests here at the mosque are you
guys doing and I just witnessed a very
incredible story a part of history and
be be young just shared with us her
encounter with Malcolm X I'm gonna let
her now go ahead and share the story
that she shared with us amazing check
this out I was a part of a group of
historians back in the 1960s I'm 85
years old so I have a lot of history and
we wanted to bring Malcolm X to Chicago
to speak from a historical perspective
we brought a lot of a big name of
authors and poets also and so I was the
one in our organization that wrote all
the letters to Malcolm's office and to
Malcolm and so when he came we were in a
church in on the south side of Chicago
and my friends many of whom were
african-american men said I should be
cool and not let Malcolm know that the
white woman in the group is the one that
made all the contacts and so I said okay
I'll be cool but then at the end of
Malcolm's talk he said I want to thank
sister Bea where is she so my friends
are just like be cool so I didn't say
anything and he just kept walking back
and stood right in front of me and said
I know your sister Bea and I want to
give you a hug
and I cried and I've never forgotten
that moment it's it's a beautiful
history because I know we can all come
together I've devoted my life to doing
nothing but bring the races together and
he represented that that's history guys
thank you at the Dean show you got it
here a piece of history thank you so
much tell that story let me tell you you
got millions our group had a wonderful
name we called ourselves the Amistad
society which in Spanish means
friendship but it was a name of a slave
ship on which the slaves revolted and
thought they were sailing back to Africa
but they ended up in the United States
and won their freedom in the Supreme
Court and so when you see what's going
on today and you think back to what was
going on with people who were resisting
the slavery were resisting oppression
and so we called ourselves the Amistad
Society and my co-founder of that group
just died last month so it's been a very
sad time and then just this week another
friend that was a part of that who was
Warner Saunders the wonderful Channel
five news caster Warner was a part of
that and immortal just died on Tuesday
so it's a it's scary time what are you
let me ask you guys one more question
what what do you guys feel now you're
visiting us here at the mosque what's
your impression and and a message to the
American public and people who are
getting a lot of their information for
you guys are getting to you got to
witness us praying you got to hear the
message of Islam and what's your
impression and what message would you
get for the people who are terrified of
Muslims in Islam every Muslim is a
terrorist right now sure we are so close
together as to be unbelievable and
people just need to do some research and
do some reading to find out how close we
really are and so similar and where
we're trying to go and I think we need
to try to figure out why the media and
the socio-economic environment is trying
to keep us apart rather than allowing us
to see the similarities thank you guys
thank you very much thank you guys
between ooh